people periodically
ask me how should they hold their poi
overall i would say there's no right or
wrong way to hold your poi
but i would like to share how i like to
hold my poi
and then a few other possible options
how i hold my boy is pretty simple it's
pinching
the end of the poi between my thumb and
forefinger
like this that
thumb and forefinger pinch is the basis
of how i hold my poi
especially when i don't actually have a
finger loop to hold on to
for instance i'm spinning double ended
poi i don't have a loop to work with
maybe i'm switching grips or something
or if i just have some sock poi without
loops one of the benefits of just using
a thumb and four finger pinch
and getting used to spinning that way is
obviously
when you don't have a loop to hook into
you're just holding on to something
it's also the position you're going to
get in if you wrap your poi up
to shorten them so you might as well get
comfortable using it
the cons are that when your fingers
aren't quite used to it yet you might
get some finger cramps if you spin for a
long time if you're spinning without
your boy wrapped around your hand
and your poi is not tethered on your
hand and you get tired or distracted
your poi might
fly away which is why if i'm spinning
with finger loops i also like to
tether my boy the way i like to anchor
my boy
on my hand is to put the loop
around my middle two fingers and bring
it in between those fingers
taking a single loop and turning it into
something like a double loop
hanging down from the palm facing down
from there
i just wrap around and get into my thumb
and forefinger pinch
the nice thing about the way i like to
loop my poi around my hand is that it's
really quick
and just slip it on there flip it in and
i'm ready to go and if i want to take my
poi off really quickly
it comes off very quickly which is good
if you're spinning fire and you
need to get your poi away from your hand
really quickly that's the benefit
you're likely at first when you use this
grip if you spin for a really long time
to maybe
shape a little bit because it does come
out easily
if you want to more securely fasten the
poi to your hand what you might want to
do slightly more complicated
take and pinch the handle
hanging palm down and then flip the loop
over
getting you basically into the same
position except now
this cinches down and is locked around
your fingers so it won't easily slip
away
which is something you want to think
about if you're going to spin fire like
this
let me show you a few other ways that
you might find useful
you could instead start hanging down
and flip up so that you're using the
back of your knuckles
and of course you can cinch that way too
a lot of people instead of using the
middle two fingers
like to use the first two fingers you
could do this grip with the first two
fingers
you a good cinch same grip more secure
first two fingers
this has been very popular with a lot of
people for a lot of years
first two fingers hanging down
and flip through like this and of course
you can
cinch that way too i started out like
this
and then moved away from it i think it's
a good grip
for some beginners in that it very
directly connects
to the first two knuckles and the wrist
and
allows you to more directly feel the
sort of scooping and wrist rolling
motion
rather than holding onto and trying to
forcefully control what the poi are
doing but ultimately i find that
pinching like this gives me a lot more
fine-tuned control
another variation you might see pretty
popular with a lot of glow stringers i
think
is to loop around the ring finger
and just wrap around the hand to that
same sort of
thumb and forefinger pinch grip it's
just another kind of looser easier way
to anger to your hands